when we're talking about let's just use  the term political Community then  because which I think is actually more  precise within a political Community  there is always a way that people are  living and being raised so for instance  if the mode of Education within the  political Community says that men and  women are different and Men Can't become  women and women can't become men then I  guess you're not going to have these  kids getting castrated and injected with  poison is that the government  intervening I just think this idea that  the government is active or passive is  no the government just is the political  Community just is and we're always  constantly living in a state of  standards and norms and so the question  is not will the government do something  or not the question is just what is the  government doing